[Musique]
on va parler de l'entreprise digital en
martinique dans son caddie ce matin avec
l'association martinique tech et bonjour
yohan salles oui bonjour une association
martinique tech qui a vu le jour en 2012
s'étant déjà martinique tech regroupe
combien d'entreprises alors on et 47
entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont
sensiblement des agences conseils des
start up des entreprises qui sont
sympathisante du numérique je dirai pas
ce que toutes les entreprises doivent
faire leur transition digital donc il y
en a qui nous rejoignent parce que
d'être au contact de l'écosystème leur
permet aussi de s'améliorer d'innover en
interne en fait alors le digital
secteurs porteurs vous l'avez dit il
faut assurer cette cette mutation
technologique
comment ça se passe autour de martinique
avec vous c'est quoi les profils alors
on a on a pas mal de profil différent on
a autant des jeunes issus de la diaspora
qui rentrent en fait après avoir fait
plusieurs années d'études et qui sont
contents qu'on ait fondé cette
association ce que c'était des gens qui
regardaient un peu de loin on rentre en
vacances on voit pas forcément ce qui se
passe on va souvent la famille et quand
ils voient qu'on est plusieurs
effectivement à être rentrés avec des
profils assez intéressant ça leur donne
envie de rentrer de voir créer des
choses on a aussi pas mal de porteurs de
projets qui sont un peu perdus qui ont
des idées mais qui savent pas quoi faire
dans qui viennent à côté de nous pour
trouver de la culture digitale et
trouver un petit peu d'entre elles un
puisque s'appelait l'association digital
exactement la culture digitale c'est
simplement qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à
une ère où on a des nouveaux outils des
nouveaux leviers
quand on fait du marketing le marketing
digital c'est du marketing simplement
que avant il y avait la radio on a monté
la télé ben on a appris effectivement à
communiquer en télé on a eu un levier
supplémentaire aujourd'hui on a les
réseaux sociaux on a internet
on a d'autres formes de communication et
aujourd'hui on est on il faut savoir
comment les appréhender comment se
mettre ou des états vont accompagner ces
entreprises ou bien ce sont des
entreprises qui ont quoi que ce soit
comme quel que soit leur secteur
d'activité mais avec une forte valeur
ajoutée digital mais on accompagne les
deux on accompagne les entreprises et
porteurs de projets qui veulent innover
donc ils sont vraiment qu'ils ont besoin
d'avoir des méthodes d'innovation ce
qu'aujourd'hui les
aussi à son amitié pour trouve par
exemple au stade de martinique tech
alors on a des seuls modèles par exemple
vous oui la location de voiture on a un
peu bougé le secteur de la location de
voiture en faisant de la location entre
particuliers dont 15,9 pas
technologiquement spécifiquement mais
plutôt en termes de business model on a
des gens qui ont complètement changé la
façon dont on consomme les prospectus
d'autres sur la location d'hébergements
d'autres sur de la 3d par exemple
voilà donc on a pas mal de métier comme
ça on a des community managers on a des
chefs de pub et du soleil je vis bien
correctement ici en martinique tout ce
beau monde vit bien
beaucoup de personnes bossent pas mal
avec l'étranger je pense à au
vice-président de martinique tech qui
lui fait de la 3d qui bossent pas mal
avec des entreprises qui lui commandent
des prestations de l'étranger donc c'est
aussi ça le numérique c'est d'être basés
ici mais d'avoir des clients partout
dans le monde et de pouvoir justement
pas s'affranchir de l'octroi de mer
d'export et c'est parce qu'il ya de la
matière grise un ordinateur et n'importe
où on est posée avec une bonne connexion
internet ou même pas besoin forcément
cela veut dire de sa my business facile
sans les taxes tout à fait c'est du
business facile sans certaines taxes
avec d'autres effectivement pour que ce
soit légal
alors on avait compris votre
enthousiasme johansen oui vous avez
l'air très motivé par cette activité est
ce que vous êtes accompagné parce que
même s'il ne s'agit que d'un ordinateur
qu elle même s'il ne s'agit qu'une de
connexion internet
ça demande quand même de l'argent est ce
que vous bénéficiez des aides
est ce que les banques sont là par
exemple avec vous dans ce secteur alors
je dirais oui et non c'est à dire que
peint pas force de d'être là et de
persévérer on a quelques partenaires
effectivement qu'il nous accompagne
notamment sur une action phare qu'on a
qui s'appelle i ts b i'm the start up
boss qui est une action qu'on fait en
faveur des étudiants chaque année donc
depuis deux ans c'est une sorte de
startup weekend on se dit voilà on va
donner de la culture digitale aux plus
jeunes aux étudiants qui demain seront
les forces vives de la martinique et en
ayant ses clés quand ils voudront monter
une entreprise ou s'intégrer on va
améliorer leur employabilité
donc là effectivement on va trouver
certains partenaires qui nous suivent
pas assez à mon sens parce que c'est
vraiment une action qu'on fait qui est
quasiment d'utilité publique aujourd'hui
mais c'est vrai que voilà on a un
secteur une qu'un écosystème digital qui
est pas du tout mature avec des
politiques qui malheureusement
pour certains commencent à comprendre
que c'est un secteur dans lequel il faut
qu'on soit vraiment investir on a du
retard à l'allumage ici avec les
politiques concernant le digital on a on
a globalement oui du retard à l'allumage
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est on est dans
une compétition mondiale
on sait très bien toutes les
problématiques que traverse la
martinique qui sont les mêmes
aujourd'hui dans les dom et je pense que
oui on devrait on pourrait monter d'un
cran même s'il ya beaucoup d'efforts qui
ont été fait parce qu'on a des oreilles
qui sont attentives à force de rabâcher
les mêmes choses depuis sept ans mais
c'est vrai que je pense qu'on peut être
faire encore mieux parce que plus on
prend du retard mme plus ce sera
difficile à rattraper qu'elle écoute
voulez-vous de la part des politiques
ils vous mettent un lieu dédié
je sais pas moi une sorte de village du
digital dans un lieu très branché avec
toutes les connexions internet c'est ce
que vous attendez de ou bien autre chose
alors oui l'idée c'est vraiment de la
course à l'espace
il ya des espaces de coworking n'est pas
que parce qu'il ya vraiment de
l'accompagnement en accélérant vérité
quand même l'attendre au maire le
coworking ce sont des espaces où on
travaille de mutualiser voilà on peut
tous travailler en même temps etc
il ya beaucoup d'endroits où ça se fait
la guadeloupe a un gros espace de
coworking alors nous on en a plusieurs
mais qui sont des espaces qui n'ont pas
forcément d'écosystèmes ce dont on a
besoin c'est effectivement d'avoir un
lieu central dans lequel un étudiant au
porteur de projet a besoin d'information
il sait qu'il peut pousser la porte de
ce lieu dans lequel il va trouver des
mentors des gens qu'ils inspirent des
gens qui ont déjà fait et surtout je
pense que on a cruellement besoin de
champions aujourd'hui en martinique on a
besoin de faire la preuve du concept
pour cette martinique t'es qu'un credo
c'est de créer des succès digitaux en
martinique parce que ce sont ces succès
qui permettront d'avoir des
entrepreneurs qui viennent de ceux de ce
milieu qui vont devenir demain des
business angels donc ils vont supplanter
effectivement les banques en
investissant aujourd'hui station f à
paris c'est xavier niel et compagnie
sont des gens qui ont réussi aujourd'hui
exactement et qui ont permis justement à
d'autres d'éjecter de l'argent dans
certaines choses et de montrer
effectivement qu'on crée une économie
qui est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
vertueuse en fait de quatre portes d
entrée de m art
les morts qui n'ont pas joué le jeu et
les politiques qu'ils n'y ont rien
compris je pense que au niveau des
banques
ils interviennent dans un second temps
c'est aujourd'hui même dans le
financement classique d'une start-up la
banque intervient pas sûr du
fonctionnement mais sur d'autres choses
qui est ce qui peut-être dommage le
métier va peut être évoluer mais je
pense qu'il faut
il est privé aujourd'hui on a énormément
d'argent privé en martinique on le sait
maintenant il ya des gens qui n'y
connaissent pas grand chose à ce secteur
là donc c'est vrai que je peux investir
mais on n'en connaissait aucun politique
ne comprennent pas ce qui se passa dans
le destin c'est compliqué parce que
voilà on va le faire mais je pense que
plus on va être dedans et plus on va
avoir des champions il ya la logique
aujourd'hui on pensait pas lieu d'être
avant gardiste
oui mais mais il ya une logique
électorale sérieux qu'on pèse pas grand
chose aujourd'hui alors quand vous
prenez la banane de côté ou les
problématiques qu'on assure le transport
ou ça représente des milliers
d'électeurs versus nous avec nous
quelques entreprises et qui sont pas
encore des champions et qui pèse pas
encore énormément et c'est là où on dit
quelque part on peut ne pas leur en
vouloir mais on se dit il faut dépasser
ça et se dire qu'on est capable
d'investir dans l'avenir et d'aller un
peu plus loin en fait le retour au pays
peut se passer par ce genre d'initiative
marc tout à fait le digital tout à fait
on a des gens qui sont sortis de deux
grosses structures qui était qui avaient
des postes très confortable aujourd'hui
quand on arrive à la trentaine qu'on a
une famille on aspire effectivement une
qualité de vie on aspire à redonner à
son pays et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a
un nombre incalculable de jeunes de la
diaspora qui commence à sentir que c'est
intéressant pour eux de rentrer mais qui
attendent encore des signes forts et
plus on aura de champion et j'insiste
vraiment sur ce mot à dire qu'on doit
tous faire aujourd'hui pour se dire
voilà si on a quelques pépites qu'on
doit pousser au maximum à l'instar de
certains pays comme le chili qui font
des appels et des ponts d'or à des
entreprises en se disant lui peu
question faisant qualité tout ça il ya
peint ou il ya 13 qualité bon si je peux
faire ça ici on peut on peut on peut
tout faire aujourd'hui si demain moi je
suis très partisan de dire on peut
donner beaucoup de choses l'idée c'est
d'avoir un contrat moral et un contrat
avec l'entreprise qui s'engagent demain
à redonner à la société ce qu'elle lui a
donnée à un moment et de subventionner
ou de soutenir certaines initiatives pas
forcément tout mais en a effectivement
qui ont un impact positif sur la
population on devrait mieux les soutenir
rio est celle où il est question très
très très bas tu es vraiment un ras le
sol c'est bien beau de parler du digital
notre connexion internet ici en
martinique elle est suffisante pour
parler d'entreprises digital oui je
trouve que aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
de
de la connexion mais pour moi c'est face
est un faux problème aujourd'hui on peut
innover
il ya des endroits en haïti où ils
innovent énormément sans avoir le quart
de la connexion internet qu'on a ici je
pense que c'est avant tout une question
de matière grise de formatage en termes
de culture digitale et de culture
entrepreneuriale et de résilience la
feue la faculté qu on a effectivement de
d'innover de faire des choses la fibre
et autres ça vient après pour moi et
aujourd'hui on peut faire beaucoup
beaucoup de choses parce qu on est un
peuple intelligent qui ont fait beaucoup
de jobs beaucoup de choses à côté
si on arrive à le qui voyagent beaucoup
qui voyage beaucoup et aussi on arrive à
traduire ses en business qui faut
profite aux martiniquais et ensuite qui
s'exporte sur toute la caraïbe
parce que c'est important on peut
réussir à faire beaucoup de choses à
tout quand sans beaucoup d'envié de
passion dans vos propos merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin de saint louis
dans cinq à dix ans rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association
martinique tech et l'entreprise digital
47 entreprises avec vous depuis sept ans
déjà merci bonne journée
merci
[Musique]